bonsoir je suis ravi de t'avoir parce
qu'en général dans les émissions de télé
on a toujours des stars qu'on les films
à vendre et toi tu es là et a pas de
film avant on s'y plaît parce que les
bains sont accusés habitude les bains
sont dans mes habitudes écrit en plus je
trouve que c'est plus intéressant de moi
aussi de faire des émissions attendait
rien à vendre parce que quand on a
quelque chose à vendre pas obligé de
vendre ce que l'on a
avant tandis que la bomba je vais leur
dire que c'est une coloration comme ça
on va prévendre pu tourner court en ce
moment en ce moment je tourne l'argent
ouais mais roman de zola de la cia ou
mac avec et cruciaux et miou-miou ne
soit pas programmé avant un an et puis
puis avant j'ai fait d'enlever la sortie
à sortir en janvier je peux contrôler à
vendre chaude dans cinéma dans ce que
c'est vrai que monsieur monsieur mes
affaires une année une année théâtre et
alors tu en es où sur ce projet de
blizzard d'après la pièce de schaeffer
cette dernière fois que je viens de
faire du vst dans scoop à la une et tu
le disais je ferai pas le dakar cette
année parce que je pense qu'il va mettre
en scène bizarre de schaeffer lens est
devenu quoi cette histoire a été jouée
tout simplement retardé à la place de la
pièce de schaeffer bien scène par oman
j'ai joué dans des molière mis en scène
par planchon c'est pas mal non plus ce
qui est pas mal non plus le tube à le
faire le plus tard oui vu je pense qu'on
va le faire on va le faire après je suis
pas dans 89 20 dans le cas des projets
comme ça je campais programme un coup
oui des projets pas des projets pas des
projets des envies et 6
des envies voilà c'est le moyen de jeu
par des projets trop signer parce que un
petit peu peur profonde faire le dakar
cette année non vraiment pourquoi cette
année de venir en janvier
maintenant mon nom parce que en janvier
je reprends entreprenant d'art au tnp y
est
donc ça correspond ce fait je fais de
gens pendant deux ans je n'aime pas sur
le dire car je vois qui leur fera encore
très honnêtement je ne sais pas non je
ne dis pas je ne crois pas je dis j'ai
dit je ne sais pas je ne sais pas parce
que moi j'aime bien marcher pas par
pulsion alors bon je les fais j'ai fait
six fois de suite
pas mal pas mal on l'a on l'a gagnée
trois fois par équipes on a gagné une
fausse 83 on a toujours eu des places
d'honneur 3e 2e 5e
bonjour je sais pas c'est une cg pas
vrai qu'on peut dire que c'est une
passion malin la seule et unique passion
que j'ai c'est mon métier laventure
d'aventuré banques sauvées par dakar
ressemble une aventure m'enfin le
théâtre est notre métier
mais que ce soit le dakar où que ce soit
la vie tu as l'air de bien mais tu
éclaté quand même parce que dans les
périodes comme en ce moment on ne voit
pas mal dans les boîtes on ne voit pas
mal tard la nuit
aubin wire d'ailleurs
bien roulé à fond la caisse dans la vie
dans une riche veuve est toujours
toujours et puis non mais c'est pas vrai
je suis pas je pourrais pas dire à la
télé donc je peux dire je veux dire une
chose à la télévision c'est que je fais
une grosse différence entre les halles
colonies lebron vous important à dans
une souris oui c'était c'était une
définition de travers et je peins avec
holy the page vérité c'est que j'ai des
compagnes et ardent des gouvernements
pas pas toujours quand je pars
j'aime pas l'alcool je problèmes comme
par contre ce temps en temps rs et
je vous avais pas alliance vient flirter
avec le diable à 20 ans est bon c'est
vrai que j'aime bien
j'aime bien venir ici
ouais et à paris si c'est quoi tes boîte
préféré à paris il y en a très peu entré
plus car samba samba et cas ça va c'est
un bon c'est un bon choix c'est mon
circuit est ce que tu crois que tu as la
même chance que ton père
au niveau des réalisateurs et quand tu
tournes est ce que tu penses qu'il a eu
des réalisateurs des scénaristes plus
avec plus d'envergure que ceux avec qui
tu tourne toi aujourd'hui en france qu
aucune question j'avais beaucoup du
cinéma léger pas non plus à me plaindre
il faut voir savoir sandra continue t il
à fédérer aussi comme affaires générales
comme ça que le patois et la tournée
ricard mais c'est avec des millions on
est crevé j'ai eu la chance de tourner
des tournées au noir de tourner avec
truffaut est bon ça va tu penses que le
compte est bon moment oui oui bon c'est
ce qui compte c'est qu'on soit moyens et
on fils alexandre et suivent en faire un
acteur un bras troisième génération moi
je n'en ferai rien d'abord ce transfert
ce ne sera pas la troisième génération
ce sera la quatrième plus avancée pour
ce que je tiendrais à petit signe avec
eux il n'y a que des clowns dans ma
famille de 1820 donc ça remonte encore
beaucoup plus loin que ça quant à lui je
lui ferais rien faire la seule chose que
je souhaite qu'ils fassent quelque chose
qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils ont envie
d'être acteurs pour le moment oui au
moment où y est
j'ai envie j'ai envie qu'il est qu'il
ait envie d'être acteurs et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de finale andy tu
es abonné vous mettez un pouce bleus